[Music]
I'm the one
okay so look today's podcast some of you
may not know who the guest that I have
on today but here's what I will tell you
if you are in the mortgage business in
the real estate business if you're
somebody that's currently a homeowner if
you're thinking about buying a home if
you're currently in the industry having
to do with anything to do with title
escrow refi new purchases whatever it
may be
you're gonna not only want to watch this
but you're going to share this with your
offices all your loss all your senior
loss all your Realtors everybody and
here's why for the last three months to
six months I've been wanting to bring
CEOs of major banks that were around in
2007-2008 at a conversation with
somebody very close to Angela Mozilla
who were trying to bring him out we had
conversations with multiple other people
about having them on a podcast but today
we have somebody that can probably give
us more insight on what happened in 2000
maybe even better than a lot of other
people out there that were you know
experts news all that's probably better
than any of those guys there's I would
say only five other people that have as
much Insider Insight information
insightful information on this topic as
you do and here's who it is our guest
today is Carrie Killinger this is
episode number one 185 Killinger joined
WAMU in 1983. if you remember WAMU I
used to bank with WAMU I loved WAMU I
was was hoping Rama would take out B of
A I was you know rooting for WAMU to
take out Wells there was a very
different spirit and culture in WAMU it
was felt the moment you walked into
every one of their branches and if
you're one of them you're gonna find out
why this is a very important guest so he
joins WAMU in 83
when it acquired Murphy's far
then he was named Executive Vice
President promoted in 1986 to senior
vice president and then to director in
88 he was named president of the company
that same year in 88 in 1990 he becomes
the CEO of WAMU now now stay with me
here and chairman in 1991 American
Banker names him the 2001 Banker of the
Year during his tenure as a CEO from
1990 till 2008-ish WAMU Grew From 30
branches none of you knew who WAMU was
in 1990 by the way from 30 branches and
7 billion dollars of assets to 2 000
branches
330 billion dollars if I'm not mistaken
I read in a Fortune Magazine back in
006 it was when they were at 333 20 320
330 billion dollar company however
however WAMU was also one of the leaders
in no income no assets wama was also one
of the leaders in nagams that was taking
place in negative amortization loan
which will get into to as well and I was
in this you know my friends were in it
they were working with New Century they
were working with you know Countrywide I
can name all of them we were all these
were all our friends and I lived in L.A
I was in LA while this was happening
and WAMU goes from 330 billion dollar
company to being scooped up by Chase for
1.9 billion dollars from 330 for being
picked up to 1.9 billion dollars and
then later on uh Kerry wrote a book
called nothing is too big to fail and
today we're going to talk about why
nothing is too big to fail no
institution no government no country is
too big to fail but we have to do this
by learning from our past mistakes and
taking action to ensure a country's
business and government officials
maintain proper fiscal responsibility so
we can return to our country's economic
system and in turn our democracy to one
that is secure having said that Kerry
thank you so much for being against
sunrise on Peabody podcast oh thank you
very much Patrick it was really a
pleasure to be here and I love what you
do I follow your podcasts and followed
your career and congratulations I
appreciate that thank you so much for
that and uh you know for me uh what I
tell you I was a fan of WAMU till today
I have checks that I've kept that says
wonder you know and there's some funny
stories I have with WAMU but it was
different you'd go to B of A and there
was that thick three-inch glass you know
where you're like man I feel like I'm a
criminal almost going to these Banks
because they're worried about what
you're going to do and one would say no
no come on in it would set up these you
know like almost like bar tops you know
you would go to them how can I help you
how can I help you and what my chief
reputation officer today morale kashish
and beckyan have to say that last time
correctly both her and her husband were
working at uh WAMU and he used to work
at B of A while they were dating they're
married now they have two beautiful kids
uh Dante and Daniel Daniel but she was
the one I would wait to deposit all my
accounts and later on I ended up
recruiting away from one when she came
to she's been with us for 12 years now
11 years now but you know one of the the
husband was working at B of A at one
point and he says so many customers
would come to us and would say why can't
you guys be like WAMU why can't you guys
be like WAMU I feel like I'm so welcomed
at WAMU this glass is making me feel
uncomfortable it makes me feel like you
don't trust me so if you don't mind
taking a minute and sharing your
background because it's not like you
were at B of A and you got recruited to
go to WaMu to be a CEO it's not like you
were at wealth and you went there your
story is from 1980 you know the three
that we're talking about joining Guam
all the way to 2008 so if there's
anybody that can tell the history of it
it's you but I want to kind of start
from the beginning your story of coming
out as a first-time employee with them
to eventually become the CEO well thanks
Patrick let me uh I'll try to be brief
on it but uh I initially grew up in the
midwest so kind of had some of those
Midwest values and uh and always was
interested in finance and being an
entrepreneur and uh got started in in
college buying homes uh flipping them uh
uh to build some Capital because I
figured out over the long run we all
want to try to generate some Capital to
do what we can do and uh and and go from
there fortunately I started that process
while I was working learned how to uh
invest in the markets in stocks and all
those things you became familiar with
Warren Buffett back in the early 70s I
was in the Midwest and then got
recruited out to Spokane Washington to
manage a group of mutual funds took a
little 50-person company and over about
six years we grew that dramatically then
came up with the idea that in about 1981
or so that if we could put that culture
of entrepreneurism together with the
bank we could really create something
special and I searched around a little
bit and found a failing near-failing
Thrift in the Seattle area called
Washington Mutual it was losing 30
million a year the FDIC said it had 18
months left before but I said I think
this is something we could do something
with so we put the companies together
I was able to roll all of my stock that
I had remember I took those houses
created that Capital put that into it
was actually Murphy favors the name and
we rolled that then into Washington
mutuals and so we ended up becoming
significant uh part Equity holders in
Washington Mutual and uh it was still a
mutual company and we said you know what
let's take it public which we did uh I
remember because I had a cost basis of
the stock about 40 cents a share and we
took the company public and ultimately
grew the market cap to about 40 billion
dollars so it was a pretty uh
interesting deal but from the consumer
side what we wanted to do is put
together a broad product line including
the things the Securities and insurance
Industries have together with the bank
and have a little more customer focused
uh uh look at things and we grew that
customer base pretty dramatically up to
about 11 million customers and in the
early 2000s we were growing right at a
million customers per year and it built
the branching system up to 2200 and was
earning about four billion dollars a
year so it was a pretty good uh pretty
good deal as you said we had we received
every award you can imagine about best
quality of service best products because
we always tried to give the consumer the
best deal out there either in terms of
pricing better service we tried to have
our employees uh both engaged but uh
trying to be a little higher on the
customer service front so we got all the
JD Powers award that's the best uh
customer service and all those things
anyway that was all the good stuff and
uh that turned out to be part of our
Achilles heel
because as it turns out the the money to
politicians and East Coast people really
felt threatened because we have moved
into New York we were taking huge market
share from JP Morgan Chase from the city
group from all those guys and uh the New
York regular banking regulars didn't
like us too much we weren't there kind
of folk we didn't we weren't Blue Bloods
from a Harvard and uh and East Coast
Schools we were trying to do stuff for
the consumer and we can go more into
depth if you want that turned out to be
a problem for us when the financial
crisis hit and in what ways so was it
was it Main Street versus Wall Street
where you were not in the circle of Wall
Street and you were kind of rubbing them
the wrong way were they not fans of
yours absolutely in fact in our book we
used an in some uh testimony I did when
we were talking to Congress and all that
I coined the phrase we were not too
Clubby to fail and uh just saying it
look at there's an East Coast Club it's
a pay-to-play game yeah you uh there was
a direct correlation of who benefited
from who gave the most political money
uh to the guys down there and and I
think they're a little threatened by
this growth of this West Coast uh uh
outfit that was uh was kind of eating it
they're eating their lunch and uh and
then when the uh the financial crisis
hit
uh we saw politicians Regulators
everybody was panicked went outside of
any normal protocols they have of what
they're supposed to do and the like and
they you know I feel very strongly that
they just inequitably and unfairly
treated Washington Mutual and tried to
find any excuse they could to give them
a sweetheart deal and give it over to
JPMorgan Chase
so it's kind of strange okay so who just
to be fair who was doing for the
audience that doesn't know what a Negan
alone is okay I heard it came from
Australia I don't know where the idea
came from but then they came alone uh
was based on what I remember was built
for those who were affluent those who
had money it wasn't necessarily a
product that was made for Main Street it
wasn't made for originally the original
people that designed the product wasn't
for the regular person to go out there
and get a loan like that it was for guys
that had money where it got broken is
when it was abused too much for if you
don't mind taking a quick moment and
sharing one of the products which I
think you ended up stopping that product
later on uh nine months after the crash
I think two products you guys stop
selling but if you don't mind just take
a moment and explain to the audience
what a Negan loan was sure there were
there were loans predominantly on the
west coast at that time and they've been
done for decades actually and I think
one of the real leaders was a company
called Golden West Financial which
ultimately was merged into
Wachovia and then that ended up getting
picked up by Wells Fargo and a couple of
the Acquisitions we did in California
when we entered that market uh were very
large in that product so uh so that
became an important product for us and
what it basically did is allowed
customers a choice of what they did on a
monthly payment they could either make a
payment that was a full amortizing on a
loan or if it was a tighter month for
them they could make a lesser payment
there's always a minimum payment they
had to do and if they made that minimum
payment and it wasn't enough to cover
all the interest that was earning on the
loan then that would be called negative
amortization or it would increase the
loan balance some
now what we found is that over the cycle
including going into the financial
crisis of 2008 that customers would not
use that negative amortization feature
to a big amount and I noticed that our
entire loan portfolio the balance that
was negative amortization was less than
one percent of the total so individuals
would do it from month to month but
customers over any period of time would
ultimately pay those loans down so they
didn't end up in something that was a
real problem now what happened is when
the crisis hit everyone wanted to point
a finger at a product and so that's one
that they got pointed at
I would suggest that the major problem
is that when housing prices fall 30 and
in some parts of California up to 40
percent Riverside it doesn't matter if
it's if it's a uh a 30-year amortizing
loan a standard one or if it was a
negative bam they all had delinquency
rates much much higher than the uh than
what you normally have now one of the
things that we showed uh throughout that
period is that even when that hit our
loan losses were about half of what the
industries were so it really wasn't an
issue that that the loans were just an
unusual amount of those and that it went
went into a major problem our problem as
it turned out was when the times got
tough uh we just underestimated
how the response of the regulators and
the uh the government would be to trying
to squash out uh this these West Coast
kind of Institutions and they they
basically all left that were doing
amortization or those kinds of loans or
real estate uh Centric companies
um uh really have all kind of gone away
they really wanted to have the industry
merged into Wall Street like a
nationalized system so it was going
through a handful of banks but I have a
hard time believing that and and please
push back yeah I want you to push back
as much as possible because this is your
world and and I'm going to push back and
I'm trying to get smarter here myself
because you have to know sincerely when
I tell you this I did not want Walmart
to go out of business okay and you know
you were the guy that was there you were
not like you know how AIG was going out
of business last minute they called the
guy who saved MetLife you know Bob and
Moshe and he comes out of Croatia
Dubrovnik to come to AIG and I'm at the
dinner with him and David Herzog who was
their CFO who was used to be American
General CFO and Herzog becomes a CFO and
they call in they get 183 billion
dollars and then you know they pay it
back with 21 billion dollars of interest
but they brought Bob Ben Moshe to to
save AIG from going out of business and
he did right so it's not like you came
to save the company you were there for a
minute and you were the CEO for a long
time so a job you know our job as CEOs
which is very very annoying job and
yours at a level where you have the
level of scrutiny you're dealing with
Congress you're dealing with everybody
not an easy job to have not something
everybody wants to do it is not a job
for the average person wants to wake up
and say I'd love to be the CEO of WAMU
no you probably don't want to be the CEO
of one was not a it's not the most
glamorous job because you're constantly
getting judged on things but how does a
company
go from 330 give or take billion
valuation
to two years later being bought for 1.9
billion and you're saying less than one
percent was Negan but the market looked
at you and now you may say less than one
percent and again that could be
prior in the last 20 years of all the
loans if we combined were Negan versus
what percentage of the loans you were
selling per your word again those could
be two different data points if we look
at right because I understand if you say
over 30 years okay fine of course I'm
assuming less than one percent is going
to be nightgown but you have to say that
you it was gradually more and more and
more and more you have four payments for
the average person that doesn't I think
was four payments it's the 15-year loan
which was the highest payment then it's
the third year then it's the interest
only Dennis then again if you pay the
Negan your loan amount would get bigger
so if your loan amount was 400 000 and
you pay the Negan payment your loan will
go from 400 000 so let's just say 400
500 next Monday we go to 400 one
thousand dollars 400 that's kind of what
the Nigam concept was so the average
person's like I don't care the real
estate's going up so much I'm gonna buy
this house for 400 000 my uncle bada has
for 300 000 sold it for six hundred
thousand dollars he made 300 000 who
cares what payment I'm making I'm gonna
make the money anyways so I'm gonna just
pay them again because my uncle told me
you just paid in again so there was a
part of that going on so as much as I
want to say great that's phenomenal I
want to push back a little bit because
if that's not the case then what caused
a 330 billion dollar company to be
bought for 1.9 billion let me make a
um a comment around around the loans
again so when we make a uh and again
I've gotta I'm just gonna do the whole
portfolio and then we can go from there
just to give you a couple of numbers if
you take all the we called them option
armed loans that we had made they had a
loan to value ratio that averaged about
70 percent
and and that was the entire portfolio
including the new originations and and
and the like yeah again think about
making a loan that 70 loan to value and
with negative
amortization for the entire portfolio it
took it up to maybe 71 so still should
have been a very conservative loan to
value ratio and what really hit
everything is is a couple things one is
housing prices when they started falling
fell so fast and so quickly that that
caused people's behavior to make
payments the lights start to change too
because if you drop housing prices 30 or
40 percent guess what people just
stopped making their mortgage payments
because they don't have any equity in
their home anymore so that's Factor
number one the second that's really
um that really changed that product in a
negative way was the government and what
happened is that product was started as
I said by companies like Golden West and
then a couple of companies that we
acquired three companies we acquired
California which were great western H.F
amundsen and American Savings were all
large option arm Originators and that's
why we how we became a major player in
that
those were good products when they were
all originated for portfolio
so we all kind of knew and underwrote
them to be careful now what happened in
uh beginning in about 2000 2001 the
government said that's such a good deal
we want Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac to
start purchasing these so they started
setting the underwriting standards
nationally for that product and then as
soon as they did that then that brought
a bunch of Mortgage Bankers in Brokers
like Countrywide who was not doing them
for portfolio and they're just going to
underwrite to whatever standards Fannie
and Freddie did and the quality of that
product plummeted now we recognize that
as a problem so I cut our loan
originations from 19 or from 2003
the 2007 by 74 percent
imagine running your business and one of
your key things and and we became very
concerned about housing about what was
happening that product so I cut our
product Lines by 74 of all residential
lending which was got criticized like
Heck from Wall Street saying how can you
run a business cutting a key product by
74 percent you know you're going to cut
you know that's not the right thing to
do for a growth company I said we're
going to try it you know we got to
because we think the product's getting
riskier and you're right so it ended up
blowing up uh more than it ever should
have and I think that a key part of that
was that product becoming nationalized
with Fannie and Freddie setting the
underwriting standards and that product
was always designed to be a product for
portfolio
um okay so that's that's uh uh I
appreciate the uh the answer you gave
but I guess to go a little bit deeper
there
um with the product so 74 you're
lowering it so on the back end because
let's see the parties that were involved
in this thing here and the whole big
short concept the movie Big Short right
you've seen the movie or you've read the
book and millions have as well and the
other day I said there's two movies
everybody needs to watch today one of
them is Big Short the other one is
Margin Call I think got 30 million views
on tick blew up in movie recommended one
day just to watch those two movies
because the Market's going through stuff
that it's going through people got to be
educated so
we have few parties involved we have the
banks like yourself right involved we
have the consumer that get a little bit
of the blame for not being educated and
just saying yes at the end of the day
we're signing we have to be educated on
the product that we're buying the first
car I finance was from a company called
fmac in Clarksville Tennessee and my
interest rates for my Mitsubishi Eclipse
Turbo was 33 okay and I was 18 years old
and guess what we can blame fmac but I'm
the dummy that agreed to it because I
signed a contract and I knew it was 33
so okay so we have you the banks we have
the consumers we have the rating
agencies oh you're AAA oh you're a AAA
oh you're triple A and behind closed
doors are getting funded for certain
things oh you're AAA what AAA the paper
sucks that they're buying then Wall
Street that's buying the paper then you
got fed that's getting involved and you
can throw the government in there that's
you know picking and choosing who they
want because they want to kind of have
as much control over this is possible
2008 I'm actually curious to know what
your answer is going to be to this who
would you put as the top to blame for
the crash that we had in 2008.
yeah direct answer to your question at
the top of the list and I'll explain in
my opinion is the Federal Reserve but
I'm going to put shared responsibility
for the financial crisis on on the
parties of the federal government on The
Regulators on the rating agencies a bid
on investors certainly on Bankers
certainly on the government sponsor
Enterprises at the Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac and definitely politicians
and it's a very shared responsibility no
no lenders are on your I said Bankers
okay lenders I'm sorry Originators yeah
and and bankers I think we all made a
mistake of varying degrees but the party
that had
the best ability to to prevent a
financial crisis and then fuel the
flange was the fed and let me tell you
what happened
in the early 2000s they helped cause the
uh the whole housing bubble because they
had they kept interest rates below the
rate of inflation for a period of time
that caused people to go naturally which
they always do to go out and buy more
homes and in that case uh uh take on
more and more debt and uh and because
um uh and that that caused these housing
prices to go too high in the short run
you know it's back at that time telling
the chair of the Fed was that Alan
Greenspan at the time I was with Alan
but at that time it was kind of morphing
into uh Bernanke Bernanke yeah and as a
side point I think Ellen Greenspan I
served on the thrift advisory council
with him I think he got it I think he
was a really smart chair of the FED
understood the capital markets and all
that in my opinion Ben Bernanke was like
putting uh a scholar a scholarly
somebody out of uh uh out of Academia in
charge of something that is very Dynamic
he just didn't understand the Dynamics
of markets as well in my opinion of what
he already showed up so I think the FED
helped inflate the housing market and
then when things needed to be cooled
down uh they started raising rates too
fast too far and then that started a
downturn and I started counseling at the
time I was again I was on a council
there and met with him at quarterly I
said we are there's a problem creating
here I said I'm going to cut our lending
dramatically which as we did 74 percent
during during those four four years
leading up to that but he said no we
don't see housing is going to be a
problem at all and they they basically
Rose rates it turned out to be too much
and then did not inject liquidity to
stabilize the system
and what we should have had was a normal
downturn in housing it would have been
painful for everybody yeah housing
prices should have fallen 10 15 whatever
but instead uh they they let the capital
markets totally freeze and I think they
made a fatal mistake again in my opinion
of letting Lehman Brothers fail because
that put total panic into the entire
Financial system and uh and by the time
that that happened you said they made a
mistake letting Lehman's Brothers
Lehman's Brothers in my in my opinion
but you're also the book the guy that
wrote the book nothing is too big to
fail though shouldn't we allow those
guys to fail hi I'm saying that just
from a practical side when they let
Lehman fail in that circumstance at that
time that caused a downward spiral that
cost this country trillions of dollars
and millions of people their jobs and
cost housing prices to fall much further
not only housing but the stock market
housing prices and other things more
than they could have I'm not saying they
shouldn't have found a way to deal with
Lehman over a period of time or
something but the way it was handled put
a total shock and panic into the system
and they all reacted they in terms of
the regulators and for that matter
Congress and others and very
um uh reactive haphazard kind of ways
that I don't think served our country
very well at that time
you want to say something
you mentioned portfolio
um and Loans can go one of two places
right you hold it for about a month and
then you sell it and then they get
assimilated into bonds and the bonds are
traded
um and then there's banks that keep a
fairly robust percentage that's their
own portfolio what was WAMU holding in
terms of portfolio versus selling was
that higher than other Banks and so you
were more exposed when it all came down
yeah I think a couple of things one
Washington mutual's Charter required it
to have two-thirds of its assets and res
basically real estate backed um
instruments so you had to hold with that
level per your Charter rather than just
selling them out and broking them like I
yeah I would get a a loan from B of A
and then two months later I find out
that I'm with North American Mutual of
Burlington Vermont and my loan has been
sold and then it stays that way for
years
so
you had the higher percentage of if I
went with WAMU I stayed with WAMU
because your Charter was you had to hold
that much yeah basically what we would
do is
um originate a full range of products
and and actually about 70 percent on
average and sometimes it would be much
higher we're actually fixed rate
conforming loans that we would sell to
Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac or or
sometimes to Wall Street for
securitizations and then the the things
that we would keep in portfolio would
tend to be uh originally the option arms
and the kind of things that uh where the
interest rates would adjust over time
which was better for us in part because
the bank the thrift industry almost went
broke in the 80s because they held too
many fixed rate loans and when interest
rates Rose they all got stuck with those
and to put them in there so The
Regulators really would not allow us to
even retain very many of the fixed rate
loans so as a general rule I'd say we
sold nearly all of the fixed rates that
we did we'd keep most of the adjustable
rate loans that we had originated but
our whole strategy during that period
was to try to reduce that residential
originations and portfolio Holdings as
much as we could our our remixing of the
balance sheet was really all into small
business loans commercial loans
apartment loans and credit card we
bought a credit card company to try to
help that and we actually shrank our our
residential lending portfolio for the
for the three or four years leading up
to the uh to the financial crisis
so would it be fair to say that because
your Charter you were holding that and a
lot of those were the more risky
products so you've got this large
balance sheet of risk and then when Mark
to Market happens and the interest rates
go up that was a two-sided Vice and it
basically is what killed wasi Mutual is
that fair I'd say
certainly Mark to Market accounting uh
was a major crisis a problem for the
whole industry particularly Wall Street
Banks because they held all these things
in portfolio or uh Securities sure the
Securities Securities bonds got crushed
they got crushed and and what happens
um in crisis is that prices market
prices The Things fall to unrealistic
levels because there's just no buyers
liquidity is gone who in the world wants
to step up and take a chance on buying
what maybe uh perfectly good asset so
there's no price so if you have to mark
the market sometimes you mark them down
way below their intrinsic value and
that's why you know coming out what
happened is we all had to take both
increases in loan loss reserves and we
had to write these things down to Market
at a stress time and then guess what
within a year or two those asset prices
were all back up and and so uh and so
you you created this short-term problem
and that's what kind of fed this whole
crisis going into and led to the Wall
Street companies having dramatic
problems and companies like Washington
Mutual reporting some losses where we
typically would report about 4 billion a
year of profitability it's one to a
negative but within a couple years it
would have snapped back dramatically so
I heard you say that hey we weren't part
of the blue blood Club so when
everything went down we didn't have a
seat at the table of of getting fixed
when did you know with your Charter and
all of this you said oh damn we're in
trouble unless we get help and we don't
have a seat at that table
well I think we we knew through that
whole period that our our the emphasis
that we had in real estate lending
because that Charter was would make us
more
um uh susceptible to a downturn in
housing than others that's why we cut a
residential lending so much that's why
we sold off as much of the portfolio as
I could and we raised 11 billion dollars
of new capital and every indication we
thought and we did all these stress test
analysis is that from a pure Financial
standpoint that would be plenty of
capital to get us through uh
the worst downturn that we could imagine
and that was financially the case again
I stress test everything to uh very
punitive uh increases or decreases in
housing prices and we were fine
financially going through it
what we didn't fully anticipate is that
when when they let Lehman Brothers fail
that there would be such a liquidity
crisis in the whole Capital markets that
we'd have a run on deposits so deposits
flew out of us as they did out of most
uh non-wall Street Banks and uh and uh
and instead of helping us out with that
liquidity of saying okay here's some
additional short-term liquidity to be
sure we get through this Panic time they
they gave all those new benefits to Wall
Street guys so they opened them up to
the to the Federal Reserve borrowing
window and and kind of let them bail out
and you put in all these bailout
measures that you recall that the that
we adopted to yeah yeah to relieve some
of those uh some of those challenges but
uh basically the way their timing worked
out none of those were provided to
Washington Mutual so we're caught in a
liquidity squeeze but even with that our
liquidity was starting to was now
destabilized was starting to prove again
and then they quickly swooped in and uh
and uh and uh made that transaction to
sell it to chase without the bank
knowing about it basically this is the
oldest bank that went out of business
1889. Obama wasn't like a you know uh
newer Bank it was you know we've never
had a bank this size go out of business
so it was a shocker to a lot of people
when I asked you a question about the
the reasons on what happened in 2008 you
know you said you know a Federal Reserve
at the top and all this other stuff uh
and he said Bankers did you include
yourself in that absolutely okay so what
could you have to like if you if we were
to look back case study wise today
uh we're going to talk about a lot of
the issues I got I want to go through
that are more today issues to see what
your feedback is going to be on this but
I want to make sure the audience knows
who we're talking to to know that you're
fully qualified to give this feedback
two weeks ago we had an event a week and
a half ago we had an event at the
Diplomat called The Vault and one of the
keynote speakers I brought was Andy
fastau yeah and had Andy get up and
speak for an hour and Andy you know who
and this is the former CFO of Enron and
a hundred thousand employees boom goes
out of business and he's telling the
story
of you know where you know he is who he
is the day before I'm the CFO over the
year the next year this is my prison
card and all the stuff that he's going
through and he said he's in jail and one
day he gets an opportunity to have a
counselor so no not counselor somebody
from the uh uh somebody to come and
speak to him I want to say from this is
a rabbi to come and speak with us
regarding the Torah and the talmud and
he would speak to him he says I'm not
really much of a Believer but you know
whatever if I can talk to somebody and
then the rabbi tells him the 600 would
you mind sharing this with them on yeah
apparently there is some I'm I'm not
Jewish and I hope people in the comments
understand that I'm going from memory
here of what Andy said the talmud is
about 613 laws some of them are
negatives like don't do not do this do
not do that some of them are positives
do this do that but there's one other
law in there that simply says do the
right thing in the eyes of God
um and or have the right heart and he
said that last one he looked at and he
goes well that's me because I kind of
knew at my core that I was following the
law I was following the regulation I was
doing what my lawyer said was right but
that last one Andy said struck him and
said I deep in my heart I knew what I
was doing wasn't right so was there ever
a moment for yourself while you're going
through because I've been in the
insurance industry for 20 years right so
when I'm selling a lot of policies and
then I'm noticing chargebacks I'm
sitting there saying oh selling policies
to people under 25 that's not a good
idea guys we got to stop selling
policies people under 25. not
sustainable why is there a need yeah
some people do probably need it we
experience a few that exercise their
policies you're going to get it for a
cheap price but it's too many
chargebacks and I'm noticing a trend
okay when you're selling a policy to
somebody that makes over six figures
that is a homeowner that's married with
kids don't stay on the books well let's
target that audience because that's more
of a serious audience you're selling a
policy to an unemployed person that
doesn't have this income they're going
to cancel it six months later so
insurance is all about persistency
placement all this stuff similar to
mortgage I mean you can look at payments
and say well people are not making the
payments on the Nigam loans but on the
30-year fix on a 15-year fix we have not
a high you know cancellation or what's
the word where people don't make the
payment uh
in your world there's a language they
don't have a default rate and so okay
maybe we should focus on these guys
instead of this as a CEO at the helm who
was there for nearly 30 years and you
were to seal for 18 years until the day
went out of business and not went out of
business that was bought from one uh by
Chase what could you have done
differently as a leader of the Hill
obviously that's a question I think
about a lot about uh you know as I said
first we did a lot of things trying to
prepare for this thing again fortunately
uh you know I knew housing looked
overvalued and that we had to get
prepared for it and the like the things
that we could have done
uh that we didn't were probably along
the line of getting out of Lending three
or four years ahead of that 100 percent
uh you know we had made a lot of
commitments on low and affordable home
lending to help people and the like and
I just couldn't bring myself to saying
we're just going to cut it off totally
and in hindsight we would have been
better off if you had just uh dropped
out of it I do think that in Heinz I was
looking back I think some of the
products and these would be the things
like we're covered in this in the movie
The uh uh The Big Short that is not
those were not option arms they were
really focused on the products that the
subprime lenders were doing uh and those
were uh what 228s and 327s where
basically the interest rate was fixed
for two or three years and with the idea
that you'd give subprime borrowers the
ability to have two or three years to
improve their credit and then and then
the interest rate jumps up on them well
over time those worked okay but it never
felt like a very good product because
people would hit payment shocks and the
like and we did not offer that product
initially
and we bought a company of a very small
company called Long Beach Mortgage that
was in that and so we had some of those
but the more I looked at that I said boy
and we we eventually closed that product
down but in hindsight I wish I'd never
even gotten near it uh and and sometimes
people confuse that product with option
arms and again I don't want to be a big
champion of option arms because they are
riskier than fixed rate they they worked
well for years and years but they they
did have higher losses than fixed than
traditional fixed rate but they were
nowhere near the problems of these uh
228 and 327 uh kind of low so I wish we
would never even have seen that subprime
market the other point I should have
made earlier too is that in our case the
option arms only went to Prime borrowers
that was not a subprime prod it only
went to people with uh with prime FICO
scores so it the product was originally
designed okay but uh but but I think
when when uh Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
got involved in it they lowered
underwriting standards and that product
started getting
put into the hands of subprime people
too and that that was uh inappropriate
in in looking back in uh that time but
you know I felt good that we uh on that
those raw ethics question that we always
had that at the Forefront I mean
absolute honesty integrity and fairness
we're right at the top of our values and
we led the industry in things like
adopting responsible lending principles
we wouldn't do a lot of those products
that that others would even though you
know they could make money on them and
tried to do that or tried to be as
conservative as we could on that front
but I think in hindsight the uh we also
had a a mission to gradually move our
Charter away from a thrift Charter to a
full banking Charter so we could
diversify away from Real Estate more and
I just didn't have time I should have
again if I'm in hindsight we would have
pushed that uh higher on the agenda and
got it done immediately but we we
started on a plan in the early 2000s it
it helped with buying a credit card
company it helped with growing our small
business and Commercial landing and the
like but I needed to make a large
Commercial Bank acquisition to make it
meaningful enough so that we could
shrink the balance of residential assets
and we we didn't get that done at the
peak how many total employees did you
guys have at your Peak I think it was
over sixty thousand over sixty thousand
employees okay and I I remember uh I
can't tell you how many of the employees
that were people I recruited to the
insurance industry whom worked there to
tell you they loved working for the
company would be an understatement to
tell you they loved working for them and
I'm telling you like they loved it I'm
telling you they loved it and they were
guys like one of the things you guys
were known for uh the the bank managers
were actually making real money so
people got paid actually pretty well
it's not like people weren't getting
paid uh you paid better than some of the
other guys did and you took care of your
guys and they were evangelists going
around talking about how great wama was
to the point where they believed in you
and the company so much that they put
100 their 401K stocks into WAMU they
were all like no I'm just doing WAMU
because this thing's going I'm on a bank
on this long term many of them did not
all of them but a lot of them didn't by
the way
there is a um you know that's a sign of
believing in the company you're a part
of there's a lot of people that put all
their eggs in one basket many people
became wealthy did it that way now
sometimes if it doesn't go your way
that's also the story that we read about
but for me when I'm when I'm when I'm
going through this and I'm hearing these
stories with you know uh where you were
at is there ever where you feel like as
the CEO at the top you know the balance
between because look capitalism is run
off of a greed and not greed in a
negative way Milton Friedman was
unfilled down to you and he says well
don't you think you guys are driven by
counters as a capital and I said what
Phil you think you're not greedy you
think I'm the only one greedy you don't
think people in the government are
greedy like what makes you think the
saint out there that's not driven by
greed like introduce me to that person
not like he's talking about Ralph Nader
at that time this was 40 years ago on
the best interviews I saw but all of us
want a little bit more we want to win
right we want to go out there and win
and we're all capitalists here we're big
proponents of capitalism myself I
escaped you around to come here because
capitalism changed my life however what
do you think is the right balance
between
the dry Factor the hey we can do more we
can do more let's get one more one more
billion customer let's get 10 more
million 10 million more customers let's
do this and then regulation to balance
both and then having a leader that's
able to see some Trends to say guys
we're kind of going on the deep end here
that we can kind of screw this thing up
what do you think is the balance between
us the doers the entrepreneurs the
creators the disruptors the competitors
versus The Regulators that are out there
saying maybe maybe we need a little bit
of Regulation with this product here
maybe we need to kind of take a look at
this what what role you think these two
play well I think of course in banking
it's a pretty highly regulated business
uh and um and I think we we had you know
for decades really good relationships
with the regulators and we would have
those discussions every meeting about
where is that balance between uh trying
to hit Financial objectives that we
thought were were good and at the same
time maintaining a safe uh safe profile
and and one of the things I did is we
had The Regulators attend every one of
our quarterly meetings where we would
lay out the entire strategic plan what
the balance was between growth and what
it was for risk management and the like
and they bought off on all those and uh
and again the bank had always been in
banking you have a numerical rating of
one to five we call the camel's rating
and we were for years and years and
years a a solid two rating and I if in
leading into the financial crisis they
even gave us uh a uh in 2007 there are
exam findings to the board I'll remember
the meeting they said you know you are a
two rating again this year but we're
gonna really tell you it's a two plus
rating it's the best you've ever been
and we're increasing your liquidity
rating to a one which is the highest in
the industry well 12 months later the
financial crisis hits because of all
those things like that and all of a
sudden they are all panicked and uh
liquidity is what ultimately was the
major challenge for Washington Mutual so
you go from being a number one rated to
saying gosh this is the most uh
vulnerable part of what we have but I
think just getting back to it I think
that having a good balance dialogue we
always tried to have it you know in a
normal course of business we would
typically grow uh I'll say roughly 10
percent a year sometimes a little less
than that our major growth beyond that
just came when there were some very
opportunistic Acquisitions uh like when
we entered Californian were able to
become a major player player there and
we're able to get some Acquisitions on
great terms and great you know that were
encouraged to us by the by The
Regulators in fact uh so we we did have
that very strong long-term growth but uh
but we were mostly interested in uh
being sure we had a balanced scorecard
so everybody got paid on a balanced
scorecard it was never just on
commissions it was always balanced out
with the loan quality it was balanced
out with efficiency ratios all that kind
of stuff to uh to try to be sure you're
growing a great business for the long
term
can I ask with that lens that sounds
like a very Noble lens but a few minutes
ago you talked about the acquisition of
Long Beach and Long Beach was out there
with New Century we had all that you
couldn't drive through Orange County
without seeing those black New Century
buildings die Tech was all over the
place down there and then there was Long
Beach it was this little cotery of
really risky dudes what was the with
through the lens of what you just said
what was the thinking of buying Long
Beach then with all these things and
you're chemo rating and all you mean the
buck stops with you on authorizing an
acquisition right yep it did well I
think the as I mentioned earlier I think
that was again one of the regrets I
would not have acquired the company in
hindsight uh the logic we we use buying
it was first a very small it was only a
300 million dollar uh acquisition or 300
million of total assets out of at the
time we probably had 200 billion so it
was a very small company in our our idea
is that we wanted to help change the
subprime market uh I said there are
borrowers that need to be needed funds
and we should be able it should be a
good Market but I thought the lenders
were charging too much I thought the
cultures were kind of uh slippery and I
thought if we could buy a company and
kind of change that and help lead the
industry to become
better and better for the customer
better products all that kind of stuff
maybe maybe we could have a positive
impact on on the country as it turns out
again we tried two or three times to
improve that get it to a better shape it
just never seemed to quite get there and
then the industry just kept growing
faster and faster and got riskier
riskier and I said we decided we just
had to close it down if
I want to read this article if you can
go to this article so uh uh zoom in the
refresh because for whatever reason it
just got blurry okay there you go where
WAMU went wrong okay and this is uh uh
as a Seattle Times yeah Seattle time so
if you can zoom in a little bit zoom in
zoom in zoom in zoom and zoom in a
little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more
okay now Center it okay keep going up
keep going up keep going up
okay the stock is on 71 over the past
year go up to see exactly what the date
is I think this is uh sometime in oh
wait yeah April 14 2008 okay keep going
down there's four things I want to read
here keep going down keep going down
keep going down keep going down keep
going down
okay here we go so a few reasons why
WAMU
um
uh why WAMU what WAMU went wrong WAMU
aggressively stepped up its Landing in
some of the riskiest loan types
short-term adjustable rate mortgages
especially so-called option arm
uh home equity loans and line of credit
and some prime loans over the past four
years more than half of the real estate
loans WAMU made were in one of these
higher risk categories that's a massive
number WAMU made billions of dollars
worth of loans with only limited
documentation of borrowers income uh net
worth or credit history such as often
called liar loans I've never heard of
that before but ninja loans I've heard
many times no income no job no assets
okay that's what we call it Nina
makeup of three quarters of the 59
billion dollars option arm
then next one complaints from appraisers
and investigation by New York attorney
general said one will lend the lien on
appraisers to inflate property value to
support bigger mortgages okay uh uh
that's pretty deep for you to even know
that because I don't even know how
you're going to control that part so
okay fine let's just say that's part of
it whoever maybe the you know the guy
that's writing it speculating a little
bit too much in August 2004 one will
loosen the standard for front money to
fronting money to third-party mortgage
brokers allowing Brokers with heavier
debt loads to make more loans is this
would this be best described as
correspondence is that the
correspondence like the way they're
describing it it sounds like it okay so
in correspondence in on the do you know
how correspondence works or no no I
don't guys we're making money on
correspondence so guys who are making
three four five hundred thousand dollars
a month in La that we're getting paid
behind like so you say you're getting
your two percent or three percent or
four Big Max say they capped it at two
percent many of these Banks it's not
just one more many people were doing it
on the back end you could get another
half a point or a point or point have
correspondence on a lot of us a lot of
money these are these are mortgage
brokers are saying these this is when
guys had four you know you know Phantoms
for no reason and they could afford to
have four Phantoms but keep going down
there's a part I want to read keep going
a little lower
uh here you go that's the part right
there as a result at the end of the last
year more than 56 percent this is my
this is my concern uh Carey here 56
percent of wamu's loan portfolio that's
138.4 billion dollars consisted of
option arms home equity loans and
subprimes one analyst estimates that
largely due to such loans more than 16
billion in future losses are embedded in
wamu's book so when I see a number like
56 WAMU loan portfolio is an option arm
that is I mean I understand being this
this is again my concern I understand
being aggressive but this is like you
know we're going for it when you see an
article like this being written with
this kind of data I mean you know this
you saw this article that was 14 years
ago it's not like you're not aware of
this article that was written but when
you see numbers like this what do you
think now 14 years later
well again
um I think that first of all I there are
several parts of the article I ever
disagree with just factually but I
remember Washington Mutual was required
to have about two-thirds of its assets
and residential based as I mentioned
earlier it was it was very difficult if
not impossible to hold fixed rate loans
in portfolio you basically would have to
sell those because you couldn't take on
the risk of of the impact on the
portfolio of rising interest rates of
holding a fixed rate so we we held uh
most of the option arms uh remember that
product was only sold to Prime customers
he had had a loan to value ratio of
about 70 percent did not have
significant negative amortization in it
the other products such as uh home
equity loans were predominantly uh to uh
to Prime customers as well and they're
basically home equity loans that nobody
use helocs yeah he locks basically fine
I I can understand that one I understand
but it's a prime and option armed that's
56 that's a big number if you look if I
look at that right now like
Riverside County you remember Riverside
County what it was like I mean I had an
office in Riverside so I used to go to
Riverside all the time
64 percent were in Flint you're walking
through you're like what the hell is
going on here and most of these people
bought I'm not saying they bought it
from you they bought it from Countrywide
they bought it from New Century they
bought it from there's a bunch of these
guys but but 56 is is here's here's my
other concern while you guys are selling
this wall Street's buying it on the back
end are they buying a paper from you or
you're sitting on the paper well again
we would sell
um
option arms as well as fixed rate loans
to both Fannie Mae Freddie Mac and Wall
Street so so you have those percentages
that were indicated but during that
period we were decreasing that portfolio
fairly significantly so a lot of that
was from things ever in the past now
remember that it would not be unusual
for the thrift like the thrifts we
acquired in California they probably had
80 to 90 percent of their assets would
be in in residential loans and most if
not all of that would be option arms I
mean that was the principal product in
in California now again that product I
won't disagree I mean it was
slightly riskier than than fixed rate
and so we knew that but you were getting
paid to take on that some additional
risk but they again were you tried to
mitigate that with it only going to uh
but to Prime customers
yeah I guess what I'm asking is if
you're giving these loans out on the
back end Freddie and Fanny are buying it
why would you stop giving these loans
out and and what month was it when they
said okay we're not buying it because I
remember the month like the month I
remember when [ __ ] hit the fan uh I know
they don't say [ __ ] hit the fan on Fox
and CNN when you're on it but we're
going to say it every once in a while so
the month where [ __ ] hit the fan was uh
November of 07. is one I remember
November of 07 the guy in LA
we used to all work at Valley Total
Fitness it's a crazy story because there
was five Killers When I say Killers I
don't I know a middle eastern I just
mean Killers like we were all very
competitive okay in sports non-mob
related yeah we've seen I've interviewed
some random people yeah so strong young
sales people driven there was five of us
that were super super competitive guys
and we're sitting there and we're
working at valleys I mean we're making
2500 bucks a month three thousand but
when you're working at a gym when you're
working at a gym you know everybody at
the club so you don't pay at the clubs
you don't pay at the bar you don't pay
because you know everybody that's kind
of the benefit of being broke working at
a gym you know everybody okay so it's
like concierge to the town right
when they were sitting they were saying
hey boys what are we gonna do and there
was one girl that was she was a boss as
well but we're sitting there like what
are we gonna do and then everyone left
and most of them went into mortgages I
went to insurance I got lucky I went
into Insurance because insurance was the
least attractive one uh mortgage real
estate was the sexy one of the guys
opened up a 30 000 square foot he took
over the floor and he was getting his
leads from a lead company in Canada and
he was blowing up when I say blowing up
he's having five hundred thousand dollar
a month every month net to him
good looking guy model looking guy
another guy was doing very well for
himself
and then all of a sudden
I get the message hey come see us come
see the office so I go to see the office
everybody's gone and it was November of
07. and the Word was when from back end
they said we're no longer buying the
paper you have to say if you're no
longer buying a paper we're no longer
proven and they can't pick up payment
loans anymore and then that was felt on
loan officers and then that was felt by
Realtors and then I was felt by
homeowners they felt the dip in the
value so when was it when you kind of
found out where these guys are no longer
willing to buy this paper do you
remember well I I mean clearly the
markets became more and more difficult
in the second half of 2007 and I and I
think the uh that really started to show
up when liquidity crisis hit Countrywide
they were you know they they were very
they had to sell everything they didn't
have any Capital to hold in portfolio so
all of a sudden they found themselves in
a real Lurch and had to go out and get
some emergency capital and different
things but uh clearly market conditions
were getting more more difficult to say
we
we started you know several years before
that three maybe four years before that
cutting back both originations and
selling off as much of of the portfolios
that we could uh again if I had had it
to do over again it would you know you
maybe you tried to sell 100 because uh
the principal problem as I come back to
was not the nature of an option armed
product
that may have been I don't want to throw
a number out but maybe you know 10 or
whatever the problem the biggest problem
is when housing prices fall as fast as
they were falling in that period uh we
saw delinquencies rise everywhere didn't
matter if it was a home equity loan if
it was a a 30-year fixed rate loan or if
it was a intermediate uh loan or if it
was an option arm and option arms yes
they they suffered a little more uh as
it turns out over the cycle they came
back the best too but uh but clearly it
became a a very difficult period but if
housing had not Fallen that far that
fast uh that that was the major Catalyst
of it all I will tell you this I think
option arm
is an incredible product
for five percent of America I think
option arm is an incredible if it was
available today everything I own I would
put it on optionr if it was available
today for me to get it the way it was
back in the days
I would have it on everything that I own
because it was fantastic you'd get the
statement you had boom boom boom boom
pick and choose yeah 15 30 interest only
and again and you know okay this month
I'm gonna do this demo so so four
thousand dollars a month three thousand
dollars a month two thousand dollars on
twelve hundred dollars on pick and
choose it was a great way of I mean can
you imagine you got four payments to
make for your mortgage for your house
that's a fantastic if you think about
product wise it's fantastic but the part
I respect about Buffett
you know is uh there's a lot of things
to respect about Buffett but the one
thing that I respect about Buffett is
the final one specific to his philosophy
I'm not talking politics or anything
some people disagree with his politics
I'm talking to the business side of
things
when all of a sudden everybody was going
into Tech
he's like yeah no we're not going in
what are you talking about everyone's
doing Comcast I'm good everyone's nah
I'm good
man he's lost his touch he's in his 70s
he's lost this touch he's in his 60s
he's not he's in his 80s he's lost his
touch he said yeah okay cool you guys
have been saying this for the last four
years I've lost my touch and I keep
losing my touch and I'll be worth a
hundred billion dollars and you guys
keep saying I lost my touch
okay yeah crypto I'm not gonna go crypto
this guy's clueless he's lost this touch
he's lost his touch you know and he
keeps saying this and saying this and
saying this
how I guess the hardest thing to do is
how hard is it to say
I don't care if Freddie and Fanny is
buying our paper I don't think this is
sustainable long term and we got to get
away from it how hard in that moment is
it to do that you understand what the
question I'm asking right because you're
like okay who is who is safer than
Freddie and Fanny I was in the military
when you get out of the military what do
they say you know you can buy zero
financing if you're a vet right you have
this loan that you can get okay
Freddie Fanny hey Freddie Fanny I work
at Freddy I work at Fanny or Fanny
Freddy and Fanny are going bankrupt what
Freddie and Fanny are going how is that
even possible so how hard is it to know
that Freddie and Fanny or others are
buying the paper for you to say I'm
still not going to sell this paper
because I don't think this makes sense
long-term for the company
I totally agree with that and uh again
no other major institution cut their
lending 74 percent three years leading
up up to before the financial crisis
nobody sold off as many of their loans
to try to prepare it I thought the
housing market was very vulnerable we
tried to do what we could uh and we cut
our market share think about nationally
we cut our market share in half
and very difficult running a business a
large business National and to know that
you're going to not be funding loans to
know that you're not going to provide
employment opportunity you're going to
cut back 74 percent we laid off 15 000
people out of the mortgage area over
that period what was that period give us
some like month to month well this was
2003 to 2007 we actually cut our lending
by 74 you laid off 15 from 2003 to 2007.
and that's for the 15 000 jobs went yeah
in that same window how much of that two
how much did that 15 000 layoffs was in
07 what percentage of it was an 07. I
don't have the numbers in front of me it
clearly accelerated as as we just kept
getting out of more and more of the
businesses you know got out of the
riskier part of wholesale lending and
those things and it was a it was a
continuation uh process but what do you
think about the way Angelo's how
different did mozillo like what was
their business model how different were
they than you Countrywide
I think the major difference is again
Countrywide was originating all for sale
to Fannie Freddie and Wall Street and I
think their attitude was much more about
if somebody will buy the product we're
going to originate it and they they
increased their market share
considerably
um over those four-year periods while we
cut ours in half in fact if you go back
to 2003 uh Wells Fargo Washington Mutual
and Countrywide all had about the same
market shares they were the leaders in
the country and those guys kind of kept
growing and we just shrunk ours away I
got criticized badly by Wall Street we
lost tons of people to Countrywide
because they wanted to ramp up and we
were trying to pull back again 74
percent in hindsight wasn't enough I
guess but that's a pretty major uh
business call how did you feel about it
during that time saying 05 who was who
was Angelo mazzillo to you in 05 not
today in o5
I'll take it before in in 2003 I viewed
him as a first of all I knew him very
well and it was a probably our fiercest
competitor in the mortgage space and I
think the guy was very knowledgeable
very deep and you know it very committed
for it and a fierce competitor uh I
think as time went on uh I became more
and more concerned that they were going
down that attitude of selling a broader
and broader product line as long as
somebody would buy the product and
um and since you know we just kind of
just became less comfortable with with
many of those products and and what was
happening in real estate and kind of
went the other way when you say someone
would buy the product you're not talking
about the consumer am I correct you're
talking about the securitization that's
right so that that Angelo was basically
just selling the stock into Wall Street
and he could keep his foot on the
accelerator longer you had a charter and
so that's that's the point you're making
am I right yeah the major dip again we
tried to not just take the attitude if
we that if somebody would buy it from us
that we buy it you know for
securitization that we would originate
and sell it to and we kind of said uh
these are getting riskier riskier we got
to be careful we're probably going to
hold a lot of these products in
portfolio particularly the adjustable
rate ones and we just took a more a
different a more conservative point of
view and um and again I think our view
was correct but in in hindsight again
nobody including ourselves anticipated a
40 reduction in housing prices and I
thought a uh uh I thought a correction
of 10 to 20 percent was appropriate and
very likely uh I did not anticipate that
the FED would in my opinion screw up so
much to cause a full Panic to cause what
turned out to be a 40 decrease in
housing prices
so you were self-securitized if you
could if I could invent that phrase
because you're selling from your left
pocket to your right pocket because of
portfolio you're not just selling into
Wall Street that's right I mean yeah I
mean we we didn't quite think in those
terms but it was really we're just going
to originate a certain amount of loans
for a portfolio and like home equity
loans we predominantly do those all into
portfolio because they're our core
customer relationships and and we wanted
to uh want to be be able to take care of
all of someone's banking needs after
always did you and Angelo at all get
together like have you guys had dinner
have you guys spoken have you guys had a
meeting no not at all no that would be
pretty interesting if the two of you
guys spoke
I would be curious to know what that
would be like because I think
um I think if Angelo's watching this if
somebody can get this I talked to one of
Angelo's daughter-in-law on a Monday
night I called she picked up I was
trying to look for his number I found
her uh I think both of his sons are in
real estate or mortgage or something
like that and I would love to see the
two of you guys have a sit down and go
allow others from the real estate and
mortgage industry to learn from what's
going on today to that time I think that
would be it'd be a niche meeting but
it'd be a meeting that a lot of people
in America who are in that field would
love to learn from so having said that
let's go into some of the stuff that's
going on right now in the marketplace I
appreciate you again for taking all
these questions I know it's very
annoying sometimes because it's been so
long for you to rehash it again to say
listen I've already done this I've
already answered these questions I don't
want to freaking go through this again
but thank you for being a good sport on
it I think we win and the audience wins
and we learn by the way if you got any
other questions you want to ask him
anybody that's over 20 Super Chat I'll
bring it up and we do have a sponsor
that I'm going to go through here in a
minute but I want to cover some of the
stuff that's going on today and what
similarity we have today versus a weight
and what trends we ought to be paying
close attention to
with the similarities you know you hear
the stories of uh how 49 out of Fortune
500 companies in 1955 so only 49 out of
500 companies Fortune 500 companies in
1955 are in business today
that means 90 plus percent didn't make
it okay they're gone less than 10
percent are and if we take the Fortune
500 companies today
that's 90 2022 and saying that by 2090
2080 90 would be out of business people
would say that's not even possible
you're out of your mind so like you said
nothing is too big to fail with the book
that you wrote and then we see interest
rates we see you know you know what's
going on with real estate right now this
last week you know Market's going to be
fine inflation is going to be fine and
oh shoot they're going to increase the
rates again Market reacts sell-offs you
know whatever the day was the sell-off
that we had so before I get into these
questions Tyler I'd like to uh give a
shout out to our sponsors today uh
before we get into this and and the
sponsor today guys it's a special
sponsor here's why
I myself and my wife we look into a lot
of products that Health driven products
I'm at an age where you know with the
amount of work and time that we're
putting into business and life and we're
going non-stop health is very important
I need to know more more about by my
health
so we were approached by this company
and we took advantage of product it's
called the DNA company
and a DNA company they said you know
here's how it works it was referred to
me by friend uh Greg and I said hey Pat
you got to do this test to see what your
DNA's are going to tell you what you
should eat they're going to tell you I
mean to the point where too much cardio
is not good for someone like me you know
my my food I shouldn't take you know a
person that's constantly going non-stop
entrepreneur CEO these types of things
on how to get better sleep when to eat
what to eat how to slim down it was such
a comprehensive test that I took when I
got the information back I said
everybody needs to know about this and
they were I believe one of the sponsors
at the Vault and they're now sponsor
here so I'll read off a little bit about
them the DNA company is an Innovative
provider a functional uh genomics by uh
uh combining Decades of world-class
research in this with data from
thousands of genetic samples and
trillions of genetics data points the
DNA company has created an unparalleled
personalized approach to preventative
health and wellness their functional
insights help you understand the most
intelligent way to address your health
and wellness concerns by starting with
the most unique thing about you your DNA
they teach you how to implement these
insights through behavioral change
techniques developed by award-winning
scientists and researchers from Stanford
University they are a private privacy
first company that delivers personalized
health and witness insights Wellness
insights to Elite athletes Fortune 500
CEOs professional organizations and
Weekend Warriors so that they can get
optimized faster and stay healthier
longer through precision based approach
to health and wellness so we're going to
put the link below if you want to take
advantage we're going to put in the chat
we're going to put in the description as
well for you guys to learn more about it
if you're a CEO founder
uh top tier Peak performer sales person
that's doing very very well for yourself
I highly highly highly recommend you
look into DNA company and take advantage
of services okay so thank you for that
having said that let's go back into the
podcast so how close would you say is
what's going on today with the current
market that we have
to
2007-2008 what's different about it what
similar Trends do we see and what blind
spots do we have that we're saying
that's not a big deal we're not in
recession it's not as bad as people make
it out to be we're going to be okay how
similar is it how different is it from
08 well
so
over the last really following the
financial crisis the Federal Reserve and
the and Congress and the government had
to stimulate the economy to get things
stabilized which they did and uh and
then things uh progressed however what
happened is the Fed got hooked on easy
money uh monetary policy it kept
interest rates way below the rate of
inflation they flooded the money supply
into the system so that everyone had
plenty of cash and lots of liquidity is
that quantitative easing is that no that
is well quantity is easing on top of it
and then they decided to go out and
purchase originally about four or five
trillion dollars of treasuries and
mortgages and what that did is it bit up
the prices of those that drove down
long-term interest rates and forced
everybody into the stock market real
estate market so it caused those asset
prices to go up dramatically
so I think we are in the biggest bubble
risk of a bubble that I've seen in my
career bigger than what it was in 2000.
absolutely if you look at what's
happened in housing
um and we may have hit the specular Peak
now I don't know but uh we we try to go
back and look and see what's the
long-term trend line of what real estate
should be doing nationally uh and uh and
in
2006 it became very concerned we were
above trend line that's in in it it
looked like it was inflated by about 10
to 20 percent higher than it should be
and it appears to be more inflated today
than what it was leading into that
period so that caused me concern the
difference today is that the stock
market similarly uh
increased in value much greater faster
than the rate of inflation or the or the
rate of earnings growth or the or the
growth in the economy so stock prices
are much more inflated today than they
were prior just prior to the financial
crisis
this time we've also seen Collectibles
and other more exotic instruments
escalate at prices that appear to be way
above their incentives
NF cars paintings uh yeah crypto a whole
variety of things now it appears that
that bubble peaked a year ago and so
we've had some major Corrections in a
lot of them you see Bitcoin down
two-thirds in value and and a lot of
other things I think are starting to
self-correct itself didn't you just say
that the entire crypto Market the entire
crypto Market assets are now under a
trillion two years ago just Bitcoin
alone was a top of a trillion just to
put that in perspective the entire
crypto Market is now under a trillion
two years ago just Bitcoin alone was it
pretty well yeah so the things that
concerned me one is I think the Federal
Reserve has been way too um aggressive
and easy money policy that kept interest
rates too low too long they flooded the
system with too much money and the the
quantitative easing of buying assets
forced asset prices up all over the
world and then the follow-through on
that is every Central Bank in the world
saw what they were doing and did the
same thing so now we have the potential
risk of a global asset bubble so this
thing's not just a U.S issue it's all
over the country including countries
like China where it's it's a whole
different topic but it may be the
greatest real estate bubble in the
history of the world is sitting there
that's what this Evergreen situation
that's one reflection of it and so that
concerns me a lot about what the fed's
done and how it set us up for a major
problem and then we have the federal
government going off and incurring the
last decade about 1.7 trillion a year of
budget deficits now some things are
necessary he said coming out of the
financial crisis yes of 2008 we needed
to stabilize for a short period but they
got hooked on it and we've been budget
uh deficits ever since then we hit covid
and yes I understand short-term measures
but I think we put too much stimulus for
too long and uh and that's increased our
our debt to about 30 trillion dollars
for the uh for the country well when the
FED keeps your interest rates too low
that also encourages everybody to go out
and borrow
so again we're talking about all the
borrowing that people went out to do on
homes and stretched on homes and all
that stuff now it's across the board
it's got consumers businesses and
governments our government in particular
but every government uh across across
the world so we have the greatest level
of debt in the world's history we're at
300 trillion dollars of outstanding debt
now which is the greatest percent of GDP
in the history of the world
so we have a system highly levered built
on the back of assets which I think many
key asset categories are inflated and
maybe it bubbles status so that creates
an enormous leverage risky system and if
something comes into it to disrupt it
and we saw what covet can do short term
but you know what what will Wars do what
will cyber security uh things do what
would uh political unrest or uh uh uh
constitutional crisis in the United
States or some of the civil unrest
things that we have and we've also set
up a country now where our inequality is
the greatest it's been since right
before the crash of the stock market in
the 20s we are we are approaching that
kind of inequality status and so when
you think about a country it's not just
about are we all going to do okay in the
short run you got to worry are you
setting yourself up where were the very
democracy that we're built on is at risk
because there's such a large percent of
the population that is being left behind
in the like so I think there's a lot of
risk out there
very difficult to project if and when
that's going to happen but I found over
a decade of of looking at it from an
investment side that whenever everything
gets way above trend lines that's
probably a good time to be pretty
cautious and on the other side is you
will have periods where everything is
really attractively priced relatively
those trend lines and that's when you uh
when you really want to be aggressive on
the buy side so if I'm just doing it
right now I say this is a good time to
be cautious keep your powder dry and
still keep it dry I would still
personally I would keep it dry
particularly in real estate because look
at the numbers don't work you can't have
housing going to these record levels
where affordability is now the the
poorest since the 80s
and interest rates probably have to
continue to go up because if you think
there's a if you think inflation is
going to be higher than about
two and a half percent or so maybe three
percent at the highest of on a long-term
basis interest rates don't reflect that
yet interest rates have to go up more to
if that's where we end up stabilizing
well breaking news speaking of interest
rates so this just came across my phone
Wall Street Journal CNN mortgage rates
have officially topped six percent for
the first time since 2008 I know is
hovering at 5.99 for a while so mortgage
rates have jumped again surpassing the
six percent Mark in reaching the highest
level since the fall of 08 the 30-year
fixed mortgage average 6.02 in the week
ending of September 15th this week
that's up from 5.89 According to our
friend Freddie Mac this is significantly
higher than this time last year when it
was at 2.86 wow that reminds me because
when we launched our book my my wife and
I wrote Our wrote our book and we were
doing our launching tour and mortgage
interest rates were below three percent
and I put some charges they were doing
your book and when was that uh just a
little battery of the spring of last
year and I said I said interest rates
below three percent make no sense the
more realistic at a two to two and a
half percent inflation they should be
about six and that's where we are now
that's all happened within a within a
12-month period and now I don't think
you know we have created such an
inflationary issue but and again I think
the FED is the party most responsible
for causing inflation I realize there's
a lot of other parties but they're the
ones by keeping interest rates way below
the rate of inflation for too long uh
helps generate and now it's so embedded
into the system that the things they're
going to have to do to bring inflation
back under control uh
it looks like the probabilities of that
leading to slow down an economic
activity has to be pretty significant
and carry uh just to understand the
metaphor you just used a little bit ago
you said keep your powder dry all right
you got to keep our powder dry what does
that mean in layman terms yeah that
means that if if you if you have your uh
uh
if you're thinking about buying
uh don't rush be careful don't overpay I
think you will get a better
opportunities in a lot of these assets
sometime in the future it might be six
months might be 12 18 I don't know I
mean you can't get that precise but this
this is not the time to say man I'm
going to buy at all costs and go out and
lever myself to the health too this is
not the time to be buying this no I'm
saying there are times when it's good
times to buy and times when it's not a
good time to buy it I don't think this
is you know how in the military it's
like orange alert yellow alert Red Alert
right they're different levels of risk
where are you at right now in terms of
buying in real estate you know I think
it's it's a
uh it's at least it's at least an orange
I don't know if it's a red uh in some
markets I think you know I'd be very
cautious of some of the more speculative
markets where prices have just uh in
where you have big auction situations
from multiple buyers and waving uh
inspections on housing just to get it
closed quickly and multiple offers and
all that kind of thing I I think that
stuff is all going to slow down
dramatically and and I think you're
going to be able to get better prices at
some point
I think it's probably orange red right
now um refinances are down you know
almost 90 percent it's like 87 percent
year over year and they say that the
remaining refinance the only refinance
activity is really desperate homeowners
that are trying to reduce the payment
they'll take the bad interest rate if
they can extend term and somehow get the
payment down in the face of other
expenses of Life which means that's not
really refinancing that's desperation so
just trying to extend the loan so they
can lessen the payment is what you're
saying yeah at the at the new horrifying
interest rates right so the refi Market
is basically code red as in non-existent
nothing's happening and they say
mortgage originations are down 29 as
inventory is starting to come up so the
originations are down 29 year over year
which means people aren't buying the
houses getting the new mortgage and but
the inventory is ticking up which means
as people are sensing the pricing going
down they're like maybe this is the
ninth inning I'll put the house on the
market see if I can get it at this
increased asset value and so when you
look at all that that just is normal
economic forces saying wouldn't you
agree that the price of those assets is
about to start accelerating maybe not a
crash overnight but the the discounting
is about to start accelerating do you
read the market that way I do and in one
little simple rule of thumb I'd like to
have you guys think about is
most people buy homes
and pay for a house based on their
ability to make a mortgage payment
and so it is directly tied to the uh to
the interest rate that they're paying
for the mortgage and as a rough rule of
thumb is to keep the mortgage interest
payment the same if mortgage interest
rates go up one percent a house price
has to go down about 10 percent to keep
the mortgage payment the same now think
about it in the last 12 months
mortgage interest rates have risen three
percent roughly so three yeah so 300
think about gone up three percent
in a vacuum that should lead to a
housing price decrease of about 30
percent
to keep the same payments for the same
house and while that hasn't happened
housing prices have gone up
uh way above the rate of inflation in
the face of that so again we kind of
have a little chart that we follow
against trend line and it looks to me
like a uh you know a significant price
correction uh is very possible and again
real estate is all local so you know
every Market will be different and the
like but on a national basis that
concerns me a lot you know in the
housing crisis it was the mark to Market
policies that didn't force the bond
issuers and holders and Traders to do
anything about the underlying assets and
the bonds right now the mark to Market
is the sellers haven't adjusted the
asset values yet which is the average
American that's trying to sell their
house right now but they're about to be
forced to because they have no they have
no line at the door for open houses the
way they had 18 months ago I I think
that's the case and and I should close
the the loop on one of the differences
between this time and the 2007 and 8
financial crisis is that this time
there's not the the same risk out in
Wall Street and the securitizations uh
thank God so so we don't have that one
but what we don't know and I want to
Circle back on this
is that the there there is the new type
of I'm going to call it derivative
Securities out there that we that have
only been established during an up
period in the markets and uh and that's
the phenomenal growth in ETFs which have
gone from virtually zero up to seven or
eight trillion dollars and these are
non-regulated and and they're all
properly we think they're good design
but they've not been stress tests and so
we don't know what all the leveraged
impact of both the creation of debt and
all of these Securities and ETFs that
are maybe tied to inverse floaters on
this and that and this and that how does
that really perform if we get into a
chaotic market and just like we missed
it in 2007 and eight about how
securitizations would perform in the
house of cards that had had with credit
default swaps with AIG and all this
other stuff that came tumbling down and
everybody was kind of surprised I just
have to remind everybody that the that
the non unregulated
Financial Services sector now is much
much greater and growing much faster
than the regulated Banks and so I don't
see in the near term regulator Banks
being in a major problem they got good
capital and I think they're going to
weather just fine but the overall
Financial system of how these other
products perform when when you know if
we get started getting a piercing of
some of these asset bubbles nobody knows
I'm kind of concerned about that so I
mean the cdos By Any Other Name yeah but
yeah I mean it's it's just look at and
people learn how to slice and dice and
do new products and they all look really
good when the markets are orderly and if
when you start taking away real orderly
market prices the ability of these
products to perform well can be a real
problem and we we saw signs of that when
covet hit you know in fact uh on the
good news I mean the FED had to step in
and guarantee a whole bunch of stuff uh
you know it started to step in and
guaranteeing it's in stabilizing in
small business loans and municipality
loans and just a much much broader group
of assets from a long-term policy side I
think there's a problem because all of a
sudden the government's saying yeah
we'll step in and uh and guarantee
things on a broad basis and that takes
us down a much more of a socialistic
course than I think our country really
wants but it did Stave off a major
problem and so the other difference I'd
say today versus 2008 is the the fed and
the government
know that they they cannot withhold
liquidity and create the same problem
that they did back in that time so I
think they would have learned from that
one so so I guess the question becomes
how much of this is going to bleed into
the stock market because if you go to
that article from Insider U.S stocks
just suffered their biggest one-day
decline since June of 2020. here's why
an inflation surprise tanked the market
um
so this is uh from inside a dow slumped
3.9 percent SMP 4.3 percent NASDAQ
tumbled 5.2 percent investors also sold
bonds all oil gold cryptocurrencies in
response to Bleaker economic Outlook the
Frantic sell-off was sparked by the
release of U.S inflation data on Tuesday
which showed that in August the CPI Rose
by 0.1 percent month on month compared
with the expectation of 0.1 percent drop
in contrast you're on your inflation
came in at 8.3 from 8.5 in July from the
40-year high of 9.1 in June faster
month-on-month inflation signal to
investors that the Fed was unlikely to
curtail its rate hikes anytime soon it
also found concerns that the central
bank would approve a bumper rate of 0.75
basis points or around 100 100 basis
points uh in September meaning and
interest rates might Peak at a higher
level than previously expected so now
right now is at what roughly 31 thou
give or take right I think it was at 30
something yesterday right Thirty One
Thousand Thirty it said 31 right okay
it's at 31 right now how and this goes
to both of you guys how bad can this
thing get okay if you go to a five year
go to a five year click on the five you
can go up a little bit so everybody can
see it five year low is take that out
that doesn't count because that's the
fear of kovitz on 19-1 let's take that
one out that's a real number right there
in 2019 22-4 and then if you go to the
last one there's 22 too right that's
only five years ago so we can say 22 was
the low in the last five years and the
high that we hit was what 36 and change
36.5 something like that okay so how low
can this thing go uh from where it's at
right now with 31-1 if we keep getting
reports like the one that came out a
couple days ago how low can this thing
go
I'm over and under at 28.5
right now just looking at it I'm that's
my over and under right now what's your
watermark
what I've found is
um again I we do a trend line about
where we think reasonable value is and
where are we in relation to that and
that trend line reflects uh earning you
know where the earnings growth are
where's the earnings relative to the GDP
of the country where it is relative to
cyclically adjusted earnings all those
kinds of things
those measures would say that we are
about uh 30 percent above trend line 20
to 30 somewhere in there which might be
consistent with what you indicated there
and that the the the problem and why I
don't I just don't know what exactly
what to put there with that answer that
question is that when you get into a
sell-off and you get into any kind of a
crisis that's caused by a shock of some
kind and you often go well below a trend
line yep and and I I I'm just trying to
keep making the points on several these
asset categories particularly
residential real estate commercial real
estate to a degree a little less but
still and and with stocks all of those
are well above their trend lines and are
vulnerable and could easily have those
kinds of 20 30 Corrections can you go to
Max Go 10 years go to Max and see if we
can do 10 years
uh
uh she's not letting you do 10 years
what is 10 years ago I'm so curious so
20 okay right there all right thirteen
thou ten years ago we're at third that
was at thirteen thou and it went all the
way up and then the drop right there so
it's been so the economic expansion
started when go to 008
yeah so from there look what's happened
it's just gone up and don't even look at
that covered thing that's fake that's
not real that should be erased right
because that's just I mean the major dip
no that's not real that's fake that's
still when you know just fill it in it
keeps coming up so just keep going up
that's not
that's not real so if you go back to go
to 1994 go to 1990 okay right there it's
fine 1994. okay so what happens from 94
to what 36 it goes up to what keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going it goes from go go right there it
goes up to 10 7 36 to 10 7 is what and
yeah okay but now look from 10 8
to go to 2007
go back a little bit go back a little
bit go back a little bit pretty flat
it's flat for a decade
if you look at that that is flat for one
decade and then all of a sudden boom it
goes up from 10 6 to how high does it go
13 or 15 no no right before that yeah so
13 3 13 14 000. September 7th and then
it drops to how low right after oh wait
7 700 and it goes from 7700 and 09.
remember that was fifty percent but this
is depart from 7 700 to 36 thou
in 14 years I mean that
that the GDP we haven't grown four times
we haven't grown five times so I don't
know I'm not here you know this this
podcast changed a little bit people
right now are probably going to having
to go to the bathroom but you know it it
might have a run on the bank yeah and it
may be like they're at their job they
just dropped their phone at their job
and bosses tapping them on their back
and saying don't touch me Johnny I'm an
important podcast with the CEO of WAMU
but it's not a coveted toilet paper
shortage anymore it's a market toilet
paper but but all I'm saying is all I'm
saying is for something to grow that
much okay so from 11 thou to 36 thou
okay uh 3.6 times 3.5 times have
people's salary increased 3.5 times in
14 years hey
what was the average income in 2009 just
go look up the average income average
U.S median income in 2009. New Media not
a median income in 2009. let's actually
see it video come 2009 okay which is
what does it say zoom in a little bit so
we can see it at 51 000. fine what is it
uh household though that's household
fine go use that one use the household
same exact comparison bring it today
so it was what household was what 50
yeah you can put in individuals see what
happens
okay so 51 fine go to 2022
what does it say
yeah their income didn't go to 118.9
million
uh median and right there hit that all
right what does it say 797 that's an
increase of 40 percent that's okay
family income though that's important
that's a house which one's the household
yeah that's exactly what we're competing
comparing 59 to 79 is a 40 growth okay
38 growth fine
life around you've gone up 3.6 this
isn't real guys this is fake you just
have to understand this is not real
everything is financed it's not
sustainable I mean you know so anyways I
I don't know I for me when I sit there
and some people ask and say how low can
I go and how high can it go
can are you able to afford a product
that was a certain price 3.6 times more
to like I don't know so so when you when
you look at this we're having this
conversation yesterday with uh uh Papa
John was sitting here yesterday former
founder Papa John billionaire Papa John
was sitting here Schnatter and we were
having this conversation
and uh you know he's explaining how it
goes to this place I'm getting paid High
dividends if it goes to this I'm getting
this if it goes this slow I'm buying
this and he has this one thing that he
would buy so
data is not looking too good on what's
going to happen with the marketplace the
next six 12 18 months you said six 12 18
months obviously nobody can predict it
and to keep dry powder uh means things
may be even more on sale the next six 12
18 months and do we do we translate your
30 above trend line to apply it say to a
market index so you would be looking at
that 31 really at a 23.
yeah look at when as I mentioned I think
the best way to look at the overall
Market is is what is the market selling
at in relation to the GDP of the country
and what is it what do they call the
Buffett ratio by the way because he
thinks historically that's been the most
uh predictive way to look at it and
another one I which we like a lot is uh
uh to compare it to
secretly adjusted earnings and and that
tells you as I've grown along with it
and what's happened is with Federal
Reserve keeping easy money low interest
rates and there's quantitative easing
they've just bid the prices up so you're
paying a lot more for earnings a lot
more for the GDP than you ever did
before and that's just uh that in the
long run that's hype so the translation
is when you print a bunch of money
there's too much money and you're
actually devaluing the dollar so
therefore the asset price goes up
yeah I mean that that's clearly it and
I'll say on this side by the way we
didn't get into it but I think that one
of the Notions that has been disproven
badly is that that they called it modern
monetary policy which was a Ponzi scheme
of saying it's okay for the federal
government to go spend unlimited amounts
of money because it can print unlimited
amounts of money and it did that for a
little bit and that's part of the reason
we Justified these trillion dollar plus
annual budget deficits uh guess what
nobody now they figured out that oh you
do that very much maybe you're going to
have hyperinflation and that
hyperinflation is now hitting us right
between the eyes and and again it isn't
going to stay at eight percent that's
for sure but do you think it's
reasonable that it's going to stay above
two or three percent yeah for a while I
think it is I think it's getting very
embedded now so don't expect interest
rates to fall from here guys I think
it's going to have to keep going up and
I think the fed's job is going to be the
toughest job
that they've had in decades you think
the right guy's in there right now yeah
I'd look at I think uh if he keeps a
backbone look at the Fed was always
supposed to be the party that or you
know that showed responsible take the
you know slow the thing down when it
gets to when there's too much going on
at the party you know instead the FED
over the last few years particularly
before Powell spiked the punch rather
than taking the punch bowl away and uh
and it's a better party when you spike
the punch though you know that while
you're there how's it feel the next day
don't just give me regular old punch at
the party yeah no well see but today
we're waking up this is the next morning
uh these two girls let me let me let me
let me read uh uh this next one here if
you want to pull it up right there uh uh
where it's a complete different story
here I'm curious to know what he's gonna
say to it and what's your feedback gonna
be on this one both of you guys uh page
four where it says a crash of the U.S
housing market is very unlikely
even as mortgage rates search to 14 your
highs markets Insider this is a story
from yesterday pandemic home buying hot
spots like Sacramento and San Jose have
a Thrive over the past few years but as
fears of an economic recession spread
they are now most at risk of facing a
housing downturn according to Redfin if
the U.S does enter a recession we're
unlikely to see a housing market crash
like the Great Recession because the
factors affecting the economy are
different a senior Economist at Redfin
said in a housing report but a recession
or even a continued economic downturn
that doesn't reach recession levels
would impact some local housing markets
more than others read from researchers
looked at several indicators to rank
cities on their chances of a housing
market downturn in the case of U.S
recession the fear in this case is that
as the broader economic Titans some home
values may decline leaving homeowners
holding a mortgage far more than the
value of their investment which do you
guys agree or disagree with this
go ahead
[Music]
um
it is a fact that if I don't sell my
house and I've got some Equity but on my
street the prices are going down my
available Equity if I go to any lending
institution just went down and so
um do I think it's going to be a crash I
don't think it's going to be a crash but
we just talked about it already I think
that the scissor pinch is already coming
and we're seeing you we're not
speculating on it we're looking at real
data and so crash like 08 no but are we
about to see these these prices go down
and I want to know the motivation of the
author here what point are you trying to
make because there's a conflict in there
because even if the prices go down a
little bit Pat the guy with the equity
now has less home equity to redo the
kitchen and the bathrooms so you don't
have to be in the market to be impacted
by a dimension of values
I get that's totally totally correct and
I think
you know back in 2007 and eight uh chair
fad Bernanke uh but very public in
saying he did not see a problem in
housing even after it started going down
and and made the note that not since a
Great Depression had housing prices on a
national basis ever fallen
at all because uh and it hadn't uh the
only time it fell nationally was in the
Great Depression so that gave them a lot
of comfort that housing was going to
perform much much better than than what
they ever thought and again that turned
out to be a mistake and uh and I think
housing should have fallen 10 to 20
percent nationally it was about that
overvalued in my opinion and it went
more than twice that because the uh they
let the liquidity crisis come and they
just went into free fall I don't think
that latter risk is here this time uh I
but I do think that prices could easily
correct in some of these markets by 10
to 20 percent maybe a little bit more
um uh but I I don't think I think the
fed and the government will avoid going
into panic mode the way they did last
time and I think they'll make better
decisions and and not cause that hyper
uh fall off hopefully you're right I
mean look the I do want to talk about
rent because a lot of people are also
right now going through the rent
challenges so this is from reason uh
latest inflation numbers show that rent
is too damn High inflation continues to
ravage America's paychecks and it's
increasingly shown up in Rising rents
the latest Consumer Price Index by the
Bureau of Labor Statistics shows that
prices ticked up by another point one
percent for urban consumers in August
for an annualized increase of 8.3 for
the year the marginal increase in
inflation comes in spite of fuel costs
falling uh 10.3 last month increases in
the shelter food and Medical Care uh
indexes were the largest of many
contributors to the broad-based monthly
all items increase at the the BLS and
the News are released today the latest
CPI shows 0.7 increases and it continues
to spot rents reported by listing
companies are grown at even a faster
rate apartment list reports a 7.2
percent increase and rental prices so
far for the year that's a moderate
compared to the 17.6 percent increase in
rents the company reported in 2021 it's
still well above pre-pandemic increases
from 3.4 percent and 2.3 percent in 18
and 19. is this gonna come back down or
is this going to stay steady when it
comes down to in regards to rents well
rents have have a rising well you know
at at a high level but they still do not
reflect what's gone on in the pricing of
overall housing now the rents haven't
increased as fast as the price of
housing nationally so you're going to
have a catch up where rents are going to
keep going up unless how you know but
how if housing prices start to fall off
then you'll see a moderation in the uh
in the rent you know and the other thing
that's going on in our country is that
individual homeowners are increasingly
getting squeezed out of the markets so
more and more the housing units are
getting purchased in bulk by investors
and those are then in turn are being
rented now that um and that'll be
interesting to see what kind of returns
that is you know maybe the the guys
doing that now are kind of buying at the
peak and it may may not work for them
too well from that standpoint but the uh
but as a country yet uh if if we start
getting more and more of the units uh
into rental and fewer and fewer people
able to own homes over time again that
ability to amass
equity and the American dream and all
the kind of things that housing has
traditionally provided for average
income people is is going to go away and
right now again affordability of housing
is is the worst in in some decades so
it's gonna we're gonna see immediately
that fewer and fewer people can get in
and actually a 4 board and to buy houses
and all that until until these prices
correct somewhat an Insider just said TZ
Burton he says I'm a landlord but I
haven't increased my rents yet my costs
have gone way up so some of these guys
are also seeing their costs going up so
they kind of have to pass down the rent
to somebody else and I just looked at
you know Blackstone I think you were
referencing Blackstone when you're
seeing some of these guys are just
picking up left and right what they're
doing it's going to be interesting to
see if their model Works long term you
know but for them to be where they're at
and continuously grow the way they have
it's Larry Fink right is that who it is
yeah so they uh again one of the hardest
things to see is when when one keeps
winning over and over and over and over
and over again how do you manage blind
spots to make sure you don't think
you're untouchable
that's the the stress test you explained
like everyone's going to be stress
tested the next six 12 24 months it's
going to be so interesting to see what
happens you know how real estate's gonna
do how insurance is going to do how
Finance is going to do how crypto is
going to do how media is going to do the
stress test in X6 12 24 months will be
fascinating to watch but look we've come
to the end of the podcast I want to give
a shout out to a couple of the super
chats here
on uh what they did uh D.L Saints I
really want to know podcast that she
gave 100 outstanding content brother I
hope uh people are paying attention to
Tate interview was legendary you are
truly leading from the front awesome
thank you brother appreciate you also
airborne and then we had another person
talking about uh I want to say let me
see if I even took a shot of that if I
took a picture of that if I didn't maybe
I didn't here we go Paul said why do
most not see this I made more money
selling my house last year than any bank
that held a mortgage on it I'm a high
school dropout and could see the massive
debt and looming housing problem why
don't others that's a good question why
don't others see this happening why are
so many people optimistic saying it's
not a big deal it's going to be fine
well I just think it's human nature when
things are going up uh you all get
pretty uh generally feel really good get
excited and that's what leads to uh
cyclical Peaks
um I think we've seen that Peak now and
I think we're going to start to see much
more of a balanced commentary and people
seeing the you know once things start uh
leveling off and then heading down in
some markets if if indeed that happens I
think you'll see kind of a Groundswell
of people seeing the emperor may not
have his clothes I mean that's all I
mean I've seen that cycle after cycle
that uh when you get on board and go
either positive or negative it's easy to
just stay on that too long so you're
saying buy a bigger rope for the emperor
just cover them up a little bit so okay
fantastic well this was great and by the
way I think I made a comment earlier
saying uh Larry Fink from I said
Blackstone I want to say it's Black Rock
that's my apologies these black rocks
and black Stones I'm reading a book
right now mode that I just finished how
to invest by David Rubinstein I don't
know if you've read it just came out
fantastically Dave is going to be on the
podcast I think next month or to follow
him up but he's about to be on the
podcast I love how it carries just come
yeah he's in the world and he's in the
world and I know Larry
players in the uh of course I mean
listen you have to this is the CEO of
topics you're not talking about like a
regular Bank WAMU was 330 320. so
anyways gank again I know it's a very
weird week because this week the guests
we've had have been very confusing for
many of you we started off with
interviewing Richard Gage who was
talking about how 911 the building there
was you know them Demolition and
explosive things in there than the in
the afternoon was Andrew Tate and then
the next day it was popular today
very confusing but again sometimes I
talk about topics that interest me today
this was a selfish topic it was purely
for me
I'm glad we were able to do this and by
the way I'm not even the real estate
business or Mortgage business but if
anybody is I guarantee you they're all
saying that you see today's podcast even
though it's a niche Community for sure
this was a podcast that helped them out
a lot so we don't have a podcast
tomorrow no we may have may have a very
special podcast next week
it's true they have a very special
podcast next week people should be ready
for it oh really like that look at the
title is that how you talk 32 people now
it makes sense why do you think the old
lady like I got a show this afternoon we
may have a special even next week baby
Tyler the way you said I'm like okay
would you say I gotta show this
afternoon
two weeks really Adams Adam is finally
working this afternoon he's got a
podcast well we've been we've been
working hard at the Vault we've been in
Madrid with Tates
who you got today a bunch of lovely
ladies we're gonna talk about what uh
the role of a woman is these days versus
the role of a man reaction to Andrew
Tate's interview tune into the sales
cast there you go today four o'clock it
could be spicy okay all right gang to
tune in he's gonna have his podcast
going on later on today everybody else
will do this again next week take care
have a great weekend bye-bye bye-bye